Rob handlery we recently played a lot of
battlefield one at e3 2016 and you
recently went back through the footage
to kind of scrub through it and see what
you might find that we didn't initially
notice and from what I can gather you
came up with a lot of the aerial combat
details yeah that's what I'm really into
i went to the reddits and got a better
understanding of the air combat and
we'll be taking a look at you know each
of the plains and the blimp and kind of
dissect what we know so far awesome
let's get into it air vehicles pilots
take personal damage as well as vehicle
damage so like in this case here's you
shooting me which was pretty pretty much
the highlight of its like the gameplay
you shoot me I felt pretty good about
this and I wanted to check that I made
sure to kill you and yeah you you killed
me right my plane is actually still
intact you shot me in the head right
because it says bomber damage but I only
did like three total damage to the
bomber right and biplanes do you don't
have it can't be your very exposed so
it's not just fusing your health with
the planes you're very much your own
sentient thing inside the plane which
has its own health still yeah exactly
another thing which i think is my
opinion very very new when you shoot up
a part of the plane like a left aileron
or a back runner the plane response to
that i myself was in a plane and like my
left or lr on went out and like it was
dipping significantly to left so that's
like extremely exciting contextual
damage being done to it right right
that's very new like look at this like
rag doll this flick though right there
it's flopping around it's really great
like if you're like when you're if
you're good enough pilot you'll start
reacting to that and kind of over
compensating almost yeah that and as
well as if you're trying to shoot down a
plane you see the right wing already
damaged might as well take the whole
wing off or you know even here it looks
like my right engine is smoking go
finish that that right engine you know I
mean like you you're you're getting
visual cues on how to take down these
plans just really awesome this is
something that I there's some
speculation but there's some things you
can definitely confirm I believe they
stated that when you start and spawn
into a tank or playing you basically
become a pilot or tank class and you can
see here in the bottom right is the
repair option I can repair my plane by
twenty-five percent
increments when I do it I actually never
did in the gameplay we did but when you
do it you get a little you know a little
counter and you are unable to operate
your vehicle tank or plane just like it
so if you're flying make sure your level
or gaining altitude you're going to be
out if I am repairing and someone shoots
me it resets you have to be away from
combat and oranges yet yeah and so it's
like an active you know like Call of
Duty health thing but it's not automatic
anymore that'll encourage you to have
like good Gunners with you were to write
just so young while you're repairing
yeah totally and speaking of Gunners I
think another takeaway is you know I
this happened to me I don't if you
haven't II like I was approaching a
bomber once and the back gunner of the
bomber ripped me to shreds yeah so this
is probably the biggest change to the
air combat in my opinion is that
different planes are now of the three
different plants have different roles
and and different approaches in your
quest to basically eliminate them if
there's a back turret he's firing at you
you are not on his six doing many
different things you're coming from
below as it's a nice approach from the
side so you're you're handling each
plane differently and I think that's
awesome dynamic and then actually I want
to talk about each plane here so this is
the attack plane it's probably my
favorite you gotta back gunner which is
great you know your third person first
person and then you got like a front
sight for your your main firing gun
which is a high-caliber weapon it was
interesting seeing a lot of speed X you
do a lot of splash damage on on ground
it's very much a versatile plane some
sort of shrapnel involve me yeah however
it's got it crazy cool down and then you
got like a secondary grenade type bombs
and you got these like flares I couldn't
for the life of me figure out what they
are so i have no idea me and maybe
they're even just spotting they could be
even spotting flares right i was gonna
say cuz ya certain classes on the ground
like when the fog rolled in on one of
the maps i shot up a flare to try to
tell the bomber hid here and I got out
of there but i wonder if planes have
similar kind of communication devices
that's got to be it think about it yeah
that's gotta be it another thing that's
interesting is this plane had these like
kind of like cluster bombs that didn't
really seem to explode on impact they
kind of bounced so as an approach for
bombing you wanted to like drop your
bombs earlier they kind of like bounced
that's that was awesome the pulling up
there at the end then the bomber you get
two of these extremely large bombs I
think these are like maybe the similar
secondary like cluster bombs and then
this recon I is what I'm imagining maybe
like he can spot like the control point
well that's where spot enemies enemies
tend to cluster up right around those
points this fighter class called a
fighter meaning it's strictly a an
aerial combat game it's all about done
fighting it's all about dog fighting
extremely fast it's got these guns that
have like no drop or a drop so it's
basically like a sniper it's got it also
a gun sight scope but with the turrets
now that are in the game because it's so
agile can like attack bombers and then
the blimps from like any angle it can
just like come up from a blow or above
because that's like what you need to do
never take down these bombers but it's
also very much a hit-and-run type Lane
basically like a sniper plane it's kind
of a glass cannon at the sky is almost
yeah and then last but not least the
behemoth yeah so this one is pretty
interesting as well so yes you know six
seats pilot and five gunner comes down
to it yeah I jump down to it there's an
entrance here so we wanted to walk
around you can get in there and then
right past that is the there's a top
gunner pilot to side turrets and then
this like 180 turret which is so sick he
can see like basically everything in
front so he's very valuable and then I
think there's a back turret to the back
of the blimp what's interesting about
these they're calling gondolas I can
blow these gondolas up so if I blow up
this one it's not operable as a pilot or
and I lose these two Gunners okay and
this thing will drop and explode on the
ground oh man just like oh and
information oh yeah it's sayings and
does one of those gondola specifically
drop the bombs yes the pilot drops bombs
as well go for those things so it's like
almost it's like a boss fight with weak
points exact if the enemy team knows how
to use the airship correctly right but
yet they respawn so like as you're
you're attacking this thing you're
constantly hammering those things
throughout its run the other points
being is when this thing goes down
someone said and I was looking at this
footage and I
dying supposedly if you're on top and
this thing lights up it starts going
down you can survive the fall just by
parachuting at the video by riding it
down the top part here never goes in
flames so then I was looking at this
footage even further you can see dudes
running up like I'm running a wall of
flame look there's a guy right there oh
my god he's dead it's like two guys is
running up this blimp going yeah I want
that too hair if my airship burns like
that yes II just LOL so there that's
probably him like when the last guys
parachuting ah that's pretty cool and
then I was also even thinking about so
here's all this wreckage it creates as
you know you get the blimp halfway
through to the losing team gets it you
could use the blimp if you know this
thing's going down you're piloting it
it's probably in your best interest if
you have one or two points left is
position the blimp and like cause either
a choke point or protect it with the
wreckage yes our molding the map to
write you out slow down the the
advancing winning team with your own
blimp wreckage because like you see
these guys climbing over it it's it's
something that you know it's difficult
to get through so that's what I think
about like it's like a strategic device
like it's pretty insane oh yeah that's
awesome yeah just make like a wall in
front of your last show point yeah
that's about all I have I was really
into it you know hopefully we get to
dive in soon and confirm or deny some my
speculations here so yeah we'll have
more time with a closed alpha and who
knows it's not confirmed in any way but
maybe there's a beta or something before
october but yeah the game releases late
October I'm sure we'll see more maps
before then more than naval combat and
more of the ground combat we you and I
tried out a lot of ground and air but
navels still pretty much a mystery to us
so uh oh yeah here's hoping we see more
info in the coming months and horses and
horses are equestrian friends can't be
ignored mmm definitely well thanks Rob
Thank You Man
you